it's funny they asked me here to come
downstairs and come and sell myself to
you and i was just checking it was in a
legal way of course we're not trying to
be no transporting things but we get
we're not trying to do that
big man tenure is castillo first aka the
main event aka the sniper bat shout out
to your baby now big man senior we live
in a world full of clout chasers bravo
and i'm sick of it why can't a real g
let me find some real love brad do you
think i'm a couch chaser do i look like
a
chaser
yeah how this is going to work is i'm
actually going to slap money in front of
these galbraith 1000 for my eternal love
and i'm going to try and find out if
they get them here for the money and
clown or they're there for real love bro
big man thing this is cloud chasers brad
i'm imogen i am actually a taxi driver
and i'm a singer i'm here for love
here for love babies okay my perfect man
tall sexy funny tons of charisma
that's it i don't want to watch more oh
and be nice to me and be honest double
standards i hate are men just seem to
have so much more free range to be able
to do what they want um i know that
times have changed but
it's still quite stressful
if i'm in a relationship i would really
like the guy to have time for me and be
with me because he wants to be with me
not just because i'm second on the list
or something you know i've got plenty of
time to be doing something else if you
want to be with me then you want to be
with me
tradition
is tradition i will never leave my house
without money to pay for myself i will
always offer to split the bill don't get
me wrong it's nice if they say i'll pay
but i'm always prepared you have to be
prepared so i would feel embarrassed
that i
didn't ask first to split the bill if
they did um because i would never want
somebody to think that i'm just out here
for a free meal which is not the case
nice to meet you nice to meet you
hey there two no no no no no
what what's this dream
i don't know
it's a potion still supposed to look
like a potion but don't worry we didn't
do no okay
you're good of course you are thank you
as good as good wow i'm good you're like
one two glass of water my god am i yeah
is your um glass half full or half empty
oh i like that i don't even know what
that means but have you never heard that
i've never heard that in my life what
does that mean
i don't believe it
never so basically do you look at things
half full or half empty if i have a cup
and it's not half and it's half full is
it half full or is it happening yeah i
like that see the way you're talking
right now i think you've got crystals in
there you you believe in energy in there
really do you oh you don't know i do
absolutely oh so you've got a cheesy
okay no i'm scared though no i ain't got
a
is it nice is it good it's quite nice
yeah big mountain shout out to you man
big mountain good drink so tell me what
what am i doing here so you need what
this is about yeah and this is about
money and clout okay versus love so are
you here for money and clout are you for
love i'm here for you babe i like that
of course i like that you see you're
good you have driven for you you know
you dream how far you come from about an
hour and 20 minutes where are you from
canada
now is there black people out there yeah
everybody always says this to me i don't
want to know in it
so there are three universities and
there's like
like loads of black people because
there's people that come from different
areas those people from london
see i like to know that i like to know
where black people can go in there yeah
so you've got to let me know what you
want what are you looking for so what
are you looking for i'm looking for love
i'm looking for you to be see alana
you've got bars the vibe i'm getting
right now is you like black guys i'm not
gonna lie why are you throwing out the
crystal thing the black guy thing i'm
just saying it kind of seems like you're
like the bbc oh my god do you think
you're quite good at reading people i
feel like i'm very good at reading
people yeah i'm different tell me about
me
you're giving me a lot right now you get
me it's giving a lot right now that's
what the gyal say it's good like i feel
like i need to be wearing your glasses
and i can just lower them and look you
in the eye no i can't do that because
then you get some dark souls coming out
it was like cyclops for next minute i'm
not into that i'm trying to say so let
me ask you how tall are you um five
eleven five eleven oh wow that's amazing
that's a beautiful thing can i ask you
something do you like tall women of
course i love i love all women so you
don't mind if a woman is slower than you
know that might make you even better i
feel like i'm climbing a tree you know
i found your tree i love that i love
that you see the thing is here i like
that because you don't mind the height
difference you don't mind that no i
don't mind see i like that i've met guys
though that do really mind and you get
some really insecure guys that are sure
i don't care if you're what's the
shortest guy you've ever dated maybe
like five seven i think so he was
writing there's a [ __ ] in there that's
mad he was right there that's right
you feel like he was your child no no
because he's a man ah man did he have so
how when you say they felt insecure what
do you mean well not him for example but
i do get some guys that say
i don't want to i like you're too tall
and i'm thinking okay cool that sign see
that big we don't do discrimination but
i'm shout out to the communities out
there but we don't do that big mention i
think it's nice to have a sexy woman in
your arm supermodel team i love that see
you see right there with me so i'm so
you don't mind cause you're the one i'm
interested of course i don't mind like i
said it's a beautiful thing it's got
more leg to play with that's a good
thing
yeah i'm trying to say it's a beautiful
thing that's one thing off my checklist
see let me ask you this so when was your
last relationship um about a year ago um
where's he from what was he from what's
going on
so you're gonna take your glasses off
what country like where's he from in
jamaican is jamaican
what no no he wasn't jamaican
you like the yardy man though but it
came out well no i don't mind like it's
for me it's not like i don't have a set
type i just think if you look nice
i like that so right now we're looking
at jeff you're very beautiful what's the
first thing you notice on me what do you
like what about you yeah what do you
like about it i like your um like your
demeanor your aura your is the meaner
the right word yeah that's definitely
the wrong thing i'm just trying to make
sure it fits in the sentence correctly
you know what's funny that i actually
took a sip of this because i only have
you know you're not hearing voices
so you don't drink but i still gotta ask
this though what's the maddest thing
you've done on a night out do you know
what
i have absolutely no idea
you just don't remember no no i don't
know i just woke up in the yard i'm not
that crazy though when it comes to
nights out and stuff if other people are
going to be around me and see what i'm
up to then i'm going to be on my best
behavior
it's funny they asked me here to come
downstairs and come and sell myself to
you and i was just checking it was in a
legal way of course we're not trying to
be no transporting things but we get
we're not trying to do that
no no no no no no no no no we're not
trying to end up in a lorry we're going
to wait to check us at douglas stanweb
we're not doing that
i mean we can't be doing that yeah man
shout out to them people wherever
pigments here we've got really cold
hands kind of
see
nothing why is your hand so cold
oh that's not i've got cold heart man
that's a beautiful thing isn't it such a
beautiful thing so are you a journalist
person
um no because i don't really like
jealousy i don't want nobody's stalking
me in that rap you get me you don't want
me to be looking up your
that's a bit frightening you get me then
i'm have to immigrate to another place
where are you gonna immigrate to i don't
know bro anywhere that's caught with
black people bro oh [ __ ] i just dropped
a fork
because i've walked in i've made you all
um yeah you've got me rattled right now
i love your
i love your confidence it's beautiful
yeah i love your confidence
would you say guys are intimidated by
you do you know what people always say
to me on a night out i bet you get
approached all the time and i don't and
i think it's because i intimidate them
you don't get approached not really not
unless they're really tall and then like
yeah and then they'll like i'll look up
and there's a guy there but other than
that you're going to start going to some
yachty waves or go walk down bricks in
high school that happened last time oh
wow in a yachty wave yeah so you're like
the yardy waves
would you approach me i would definitely
approach you i've got a lot of
confidence [ __ ] i'll just go in
but if you if you're like we're on the
street and i see you and you see me
looking at you because i will look at
you i won't be afraid to come to you i
feel like i don't ever want to be a pest
you get me a man don't want to end up on
a register right that's mad i don't want
to be walking up to random girl moving
mad i don't like that we don't know yeah
i like i like making sure that
everything is cool i like to feel the
signs and read the signs and know you
like me i like you and that's cool but
how would you know that unless you come
and talk to me
has to be in a nice little environment i
mean so you wouldn't see me on the road
and then come and chat to me nah but
where would i see you though where would
i see if i was to see you on the road
oh wow i like that you're good you're
dangerous
so look speaking of dangerous i'll ask
you this question i do a mad thing
licking off a man's heads up wiped off
his whole bloodline he's no longer on
this earth and the feds come
take me away and they say yo bro
you're going to be doing 20 years back
the man is in there brother they're
hungry they want to take your party
that's mad i'm a handsome guy brother
you get me i've got good skin wrapped
then men will try and have their way
rather semantic in there yeah so then
i'll go do 20 years
would you hold it down for the 20 years
where are we in the state of our
relationship in dane for one year okay
date of one year um have you told me
that you love me yeah
i love you too
so yeah
so then what are you doing you're
waiting
oh i'm waiting if you love me and i love
you i'm gonna wait if it's gonna work if
i if i feel like it's the right
situation to be in you're gonna have
great pubes by then though if you feel
about that i might have great views
but let me ask you this though yeah
in that 20 years there's a lot of
changes are you gonna be faithful during
that time right okay so i would if it's
the right situation and i wouldn't be in
a relationship with somebody for a year
if i didn't want to be with him forever
because i don't really like to waste
time i can't be bothered with this
dating for a long time because there's
no reason
because you see the thing is people say
that but then you go inside and they
move on it's a three to five business
days i know another willie amazon prime
thing they're on a willy that's one
night even in delivery willy we'll have
to see how we go then but just maybe
just how about don't lick someone's head
off and go to prison
but what if i did it for you
you wouldn't need to do it for me
because i won't put you in a situation
where you need to do it yeah i've got to
choose you for that see i love that you
know why not putting the menu in danger
i love that you get me man then watch
out for them yeah big man team got to be
careful out here they really are real
i'm telling you you definitely have to
be careful so let me ask you something
tell me are you a freaky person now well
i feel like this is a discussion that i
really shouldn't have when you know that
other people around i think that you
would need to find out for yourself
you might like that but without getting
too deep into it are you a pleaser or
you like to receive once you like
definitely please
gotta make sure that my man's happy so
you're dominant there's a difference
isn't there knowing that you're pleasing
your man and being dominant
or submissive i just i like a bit of you
know i like i like a man who knows what
he's doing take control but he can know
that i know what i'm doing i like that
yeah see so you ever been off a guy
that's an experience he don't know what
he's doing he's like a dj's like you
don't know the next mix like you don't
know what he's doing nipples he don't
know what's going on they have a benefit
like that i don't know think so never i
just feel like if i'm going to be with
somebody like that it's because we've
got a connection so if you have a
connection with somebody then you're
already going to be
amalgamating nicely i like that i like
that
you've been talking to a guy for a long
time a lot of connecting things are good
you like his aura he likes your aura
about to sleep together
pulls out his willy
it's three inches bev what hard or soft
hard that's his best okay
that's when his man's ready man yeah his
soldiers has that attention like his
[ __ ] is ready right show me how big is
three inches i don't know like that
that's how small is williams do they do
condoms at small i don't know about this
they should just
know to be fair i definitely don't know
about it that's not my life i don't know
about shout out to them small willy men
out there about big mention i don't know
about our life like you've been with a
girl okay it was good and then you see
her again and then you're like [ __ ]
where did that come from to be fair i've
had that once yeah and that's only
because like
hopefully smell like a bag of rats
brother i smell it like i smell and i
nearly got alopecia brother i was like
yo
[ __ ] nearly gave me an illness breath i
was like
yo semantic and then you lost my mind
terrible i thought my nose hairs
everything was burning off that's him
was mad hang on let me get this straight
so you went out with her the first time
you slept with her and that was no no we
was talking all that stuff then she came
around to the yard we got down to that i
took the knickers off and i was like yo
so why did you go back for round two
ding ding no no i didn't and we never
spoke
where did you find him i don't want it
facebook okay that's where you went
wrong
can i answer your questions go on you of
course you can what what are you looking
for like an ideal situation if you could
have anything i'm looking for love i'm
looking for a serious thing because i've
got to settle down now i'm on that
straight path i can't i've done my mad
thing and it's time to settle down and
what are your checklists your body can't
go be in check that's number one okay i
can't be beaten about kind of be any of
my brethren so you're gonna ask them now
the truth will come out in time so like
let's say for example i say it's true
let's say you tell me free
and the next week i'll ask you is like
15 breath
next time i ask you starts moving mad i
got a no but at the same time the truth
will reveal itself i wouldn't ask but
the next thing as well which is very
very important you kind of smash none of
my virgins
because i can't go over to my bridges
yard and he's beating my girl and that's
mad then you can cuss me out
it cuts me out any moment made me feel
like a waist man i can't do that okay so
sexually okay i understand what about
the rest of what about the serious stuff
you're gonna be able to hold it down and
make your own peas bro because i'm
giving you [ __ ] all right they should
i'll treat you out to you nice give you
a nice ting brother when you start
asking me for a matching brother
that's something you gotta cut off the
ting brother because man's name is not
halifax bro his name is not lloyd's tsb
brev i'm not santander brother you get
me i can't do that right you get me but
i do treat you good i mean i treat you
nice and do things together like i said
but when you start thinking it's a monzo
bank accounting
hell no but i've got gotta move on and
get on with my life rev give you the
gummy wish you the best
since i wouldn't ask for that from a guy
anyway nothing no no i would like to be
offered stuff if anything i'm not gonna
ask that's a bit embarrassing never been
flown out
what if a guy from dubai message you
said yo do i not do i know this guy no
let's say he's just a random man he just
messaged you and he said yo
20 bags in your account by tonight just
come over i just wants to like that's
the setup straight away menace wants to
eat some food off you no that's really
weird
wants to have like man this wants to
have a little kebab off you in there you
get me that's why you're naked
of 20 man around like i value my life a
lot more no no no see that's a beautiful
some girl don't yeah thanks for you know
you and a lorry and it's men
some guys do you know any girl that do
that though no i don't think so we just
need their instagrams for research
because some of them and them need to
know about it i see it though i see it
online and i wonder like obviously you
wonder how fake is all of this [ __ ] but
i see it i think because they're all
right
have you ever been off a broke guy
would you ever date a bro guy i i have
yeah i mean i've been broke myself with
a guy who's broken i love that honestly
so you always work together yeah you lot
found love in a hopeless place that's
man shout out to rihanna big man
so wow you've really done that how long
did that last maybe um
like six months six months that's quite
a long time how broke was you know what
was broke but how what was his bro like
job seekers broke
is that like that's the bits in it well
i guess so i mean i don't really know
how else to describe it but like in
between places and stuff but did he try
and hide it from you no no no he was
straight up at the beginning but that's
what i appreciate if you're honest then
i can move forward with it so he was
honest like babies these people are
sanctioning me about [ __ ] these people
like he was serious like that why not
like that for me i won't just go and
find somebody online and think you look
nice this is your lifestyle let me go
out with you i like to meet somebody
have a rapport with them get to know
them as a person and then if like
yeah if it's nice then it's nice i was
saying earlier i don't really date much
um i can't be bothered with all of that
i just would rather find somebody nice
that i vibe with and then if it's the
right thing to to do then it's the right
thing have you ever dated anybody famous
because you look you're beautiful you
must have you're so sweet such a charm
aren't you dating anybody famous anybody
known any rappers any footballers i need
to live
no the way you laugh that's a yes
that's what definitely is
so you dated anybody famous though yeah
i have how famous are we talking about
we're talking about like local rapper
mixtapes one or two mixtape but we're
talking about like we're talking about
like i can't go much further because
like i don't really want to shout him
out so there would be no he they're
known like that yeah
that's a matching that's amazing but
it's not really a big deal though it's
just it's what it is i don't know who he
was when we met but then he became no no
he was already there i just didn't know
who you are he doesn't know yeah i
didn't know so i got to know him so he's
a nice guy and then i was like ah isn't
that you i saw him on instagram story
and i was like oh okay so he was a big
deal he was a big big deal it depends
like what your lifestyle is who you
follow what your interests are
so why did that end
um he was just too busy and i thought
okay that's fine but he was too busy in
a way that he was obviously wasn't that
into me ah so i was about to say busy in
the track we're busy like bookings and
that like busy bookings
yeah no he was cool like like we would
still be on a friendship level nothing
bad happened but i feel like if you
haven't got time for me not in a needy
way just in a you need to call me once a
month come on yeah well that's a bit of
a commitment though once a month do you
really think so that's that's a bit yeah
i mean that's
that's a bit but i've got to say this
listen look at this yeah so basically
let's say i'm struggling i'm broke my
life's match up like i'm done out here
people keep on sanctioning my papers i'm
looking for a nice park bench to sleep
on for the night that's how mad my
life's about to be and we're together
i'm about to lose everything yeah [ __ ]
yourself in ikea buy myself an ikea
sleep in the beds
i'm black they'll say i'm a thief and a
homeless man that's mad let's say for
example that's my life right your
favorite rapper comes in who's your
favorite rapper by the way yes
big man thing i love that pressure and
pain in all digital platforms but
pigmenting let's say ain't me let's say
somebody else who's your favorite rapper
i know you say rapper but the music that
i listen yeah yeah okay now that rappers
you know for sure yeah okay okay let's
say oozy brother little oozy for example
like i'm done out here little uzi rolls
up got the colored hair and all that
[ __ ] as well there you go
so he pulls up he's got the big boy big
boy rolly chains gold diamonds jewels
and all that right yeah pulls up in the
big boy whip yeah you see me on the park
bench i'm like babies i need to get a
newspaper like this but my life's all
[ __ ] up he pulls up and he's like yo
what go on babes you should be [ __ ]
with that bread over there he's a waste
man you should come over here and fight
with me i'm about to fly you out
you're going to go with him and i i'm
already with you in this situation right
yeah we're together we're together then
i'd be like no i'm in a relationship
with somebody
would you really do that yeah because
i'm not being funny but whether or not
you're thinking to yourself that would
be nice is a different thing but i would
never leave who i'm with what a
violation are you mad i'm gonna just
leave my boyfriend to be with somebody
else so even if my life gets mad like i
ain't got no toilet paper i've got to
use a leaf to wipe my ass that's how mad
life is
so you're going to i don't want to be
with you i'm with you because i want to
be with you it doesn't define you does
it you being in that situation
forever it's not you write your own
story like you can
i love that that's positive stuff so
even if little uzi is trying to fly to
the maldives you're gonna stick with me
in that park bench that's beautiful i
would just say to him look if you're
offering to do this then help us out
come
why not go and do your thing or just
like why you you know i'd probably be
annoyed that you'd approach me i like
that yeah i'd be fasted don't get me
wrong i'd be drafted but like i'm not
right now so you're going to take the
leap of faith right now yeah mm-hmm
there you go i would never do that
like my credit with the lord is not that
good went blind you know
imagine that yeah yeah she jumped in
there i popped crazy yeah don't do it
it's not worth it no i'm trying to stay
grounded bro like i said my credit with
the lord ain't good like literally my
thing was snap rather than cementing for
me i'm saying so let's say you were to
take that leap of faith and has to put
1 000 pounds right here for you a
thousand pounds right there gbp or
whatever the hell yeah
and i picked love which is me pursuing
love which is me which would you choose
is it genuine it's genuine love pursuing
love yeah pursuing love which would you
choose pursuing love
would you choose the dinars the money
i'm going to pursue love and we can make
more than the grand together can't we
either you change [ __ ] are you being
wrong why would i be chatting [ __ ] i do
my own thing i'm doing my own thing i
don't need your money i'm not
trying to be rude
i've got my own i stand on my own two
feet i'm an independent person we'll do
it together would you be doing only fans
i wouldn't i wouldn't do it would you be
with somebody that has
no
no no i'm not trying to everybody seen
my girl's nanny and that that's a bit
mad i can't do that would you do one
with somebody that did have it and then
you got with them and then she stopped
it depends how many men she's got
they're messing up their thing but like
bear man on that is drilling out the
thing i can't really be in there like if
it's just if it's just online
i don't know about i'd have to see her
cv of work like if i go there and i see
and i see you like being some mad wesley
pipes lexington still brother woody
looking like a snake rav it might be a
magic that might put me off okay i mean
depending on how mad it is they get me i
don't want to have nightmares i don't
have ptsd but you gave me it's real so i
like the fact that you ain't but shout
out to the gallon that i do
get me
so big man ting i've had a great time
with you it's been amazing you're
beautiful it's a nice time yeah okay
thank you how have you found i've had a
great day
so how do you find it how have you found
the day it's been really nice to see you
i think i feel like we're getting on
well with each other we are getting i
just want to see your eyes i want to
share and then i can really really tell
like how you actually feel we're gonna
get to that big mentality i'll put the
plate there no no we can't be doing them
things they can't be exposing truth or
not through our eyes
no but for real though i think that
we're getting on nicely i'd like to see
i'd like to definitely see you again i
love that let's do a little that shall
we with my crazy done now what about you
with me i like your look i like the hair
you're beautiful i like the hair that's
i like the hair you start your thing out
beautiful okay thank you yeah that's
dope i like that so i've had a i've had
a great time you gave me i've just been
getting to know you like i said the
height thing in a problem like i said if
it was manners go to turkey brev
break up the kneecaps five inches then
i've i've been seeing about stuff like
that these documentaries i'm saying that
i'm doing say wow i'm six eight
so as you know i'm trying to find the
right one i'm on a serious thing so i'm
going to be very careful there's a lot
of girl out there they're chasing clout
or they're trying to finesse man how do
i know you're not trying to do that has
our date not showing you that i'm quite
genuine person you seem very very
genuine but it could be with smoke and
mirrors is it smoking mirrors well i can
tell you that it's not but isn't that
like a difficult thing about life that
you could be with somebody for a year
and then you think everything's all fine
and then it's not you have to take a
chance with somebody and you have to um
just really get to know the person i
like that as much as you can so you're
not trying to take me into the cleaners
than that you get me
yeah see yeah washing machine at home
see that's it yeah and on that note
cheers to a great day thank you for
having me anytime i have to happy to see
you lovely to see you too see cool hey
don't know don't see me again anyway
obviously
let me say goodbye to you okay
hey man take care of yourself do we get
to again same journey huh
yo come back you see that there you see
that that empties there but then model
things but i can break that down there
you can break that down to size where we
get
i saw me but big man team
i'm going to be telling you a lot to
step forward and i'm going to be
eliminating one by one i tell that
you're on some [ __ ] and you're
trying to trick me but i see right
through you the beautiful lady that i
would like to choose
is
you